brooks kepca might be the beat got to
beat at the pga championship but it's
hard to beat the story that alex knoll
is going to tell you about he's a pga
professional he's a high school golf
coach he's a math teacher
and he got invited to play in the pga
championship
and yesterday shot a 7 over 77
and alex joins us from san francisco how
are you alex
great dan thanks for having me this is
so cool okay
just give people an idea uh you're from
pennsylvania
and you're a math teacher there you're
the high school coach and
when do you find out that you're gonna
be playing in the pj championship
so it goes back to mid-march i'm
actually giving a lesson
and i get an email that they canceled
our pga club professional championship
which was supposed to be in austin texas
um but that got canceled at the time due
to covid
and there's a link at the bottom of the
email just saying
top 20 on last year's national points
list gets invited
well i guess for some reason i clicked
that link because i'm like i'd like to
see you who are the lucky 20. and i open
the email i'm in 11th place
i'm like how the hell am i in this golf
um so it said though if they don't
reschedule the pga
if it's still held in may i'm in the
event so right away
screenshot it send it to my parents send
it to all my friends i'm in the pga
next morning they postponed the pga i'm
like oh boy here we go
so the rest of the summer we're waiting
to see if they're going to reschedule
the club pro
back into austin texas they eventually
did
and by the end of june it just
austin was not a place to have a golf
tournament with 300 guys coming in
so then they postponed and eventually
canceled that again
and i was officially in the field about
three and a half weeks ago
how much golf have you been playing
actually way too much
as a club pro we play minimally so
i've been playing probably four days a
week up leading out
coming out here and i played two and a
half practice rounds this week
and i said to my caddy after i hit 100
balls perfect yesterday on the range i
said
we're way too prepared this is not going
to go well
[Laughter]
on the course and so i played pretty
well but a couple of my swings were
nervy and that's why i shot the score i
did
what was that like when they announced
you on the first tee
you can't seem as a teacher you can't
you always want to prepare your students
for these scenarios
you can't do it without that experience
i'm always an experienced
based teacher and when they announced my
name
i took two deep breaths i probably said
two hail marys
and i aimed 30 more 30 yards more
right because i knew i was just gonna
pull hook it and actually hit it pretty
softly just into the left side of the
rough
uh just missing the fairway and all
things consider is a pretty good drive
but here you are on the driving range
and and i
the only way i can relate to this is
when i played in the pebble beach
pro-am you're there with pros right next
to you
and i have nick faldo right there next
to me at
the pebble beach pro-am you're hitting
with the other pros
who were you next to on the driving
range and how surreal was that
um well wednesday well monday when i got
there i was the first guy in the range
which was great because no one had to
see what i was doing on my initial first
couple shots on the range
and then rory shows up i'm like that's
nice we see him bomb the ball
uh wednesday was the coolest after i got
done with my nine holes i go to the far
right range again and then just brooks
walks up right next to me
parks his bag down and then spieth two
on the other side of me
parks his bag down i look at my guys i'm
like what the heck
um and i'll be honest yesterday i was
next to some jm
and i'm not trying to sound confident
but i probably hit it way better than
him on the range i mean i was like
stripe show golf course it was not there
[Laughter]
that's what happens i'm really good on
the range
exactly it's just that long walk
it's a short walk usually from the range
to that first tee but boy
it's a long distance away from being on
the range
well even a funnier story is i was
i was finishing up my practice yesterday
on the chipping green and i look up and
phil nicholson
is directly across from me chipping to
the same flag
so i turn to my guys i'm like you have
to take a picture of this
as i get back over the ball i then blade
one right at
him and
he's like thank god i moved i'm like
yeah you got to watch out around here
and he says stay
safe out there and i said no i'm fine
[Laughter]
he's looking at and my captain says to
him that was with the phil mickelson
grind callaway wedge and he turns around
he's like no it wasn't
so we had a good lap back over into
putting green to talk to us before i
teed off so that was really cool oh and
all you want to do is
get through unscathed you know you're
not winning but in your mind you want to
compete but you just don't want to
embarrass yourself and here you are
trying to be cool and you nearly take
out phil mickelson
it's on it was i i sculled one into rory
on monday
if i get if i could somehow see tiger
today i'll probably purposely blade one
towards him to say i got all three
what was the shot that you're gonna you
took away from the first round where you
went
that's pretty damn good 18
um was the shot i got on espn scott van
pelt was announcing me had all my
buddies sent it to me i had to
hit a good drive that just didn't clear
the rough on the left side of the ravine
i had to kind of hack it out i had 55
yards in
and the pin was tucked just over the
left bunker
and i actually just put in a 64 degree
wedge this week because of the rough and
the bunkers
and for me if i take a pretty full swing
at it i can hit it about 55
and i hit it about 55 yards and eight
inches i mean i stuffed it right in
there
so that was really cool and actually i
was only two over
on the front that was my first nine so i
was kind of
in the flow of the round until i got to
five and six where i made a double and a
boog and that's where the score got a
little higher
he's alex knowl he is uh from eastern
pennsylvania he's a high school math
teacher
uh led the uh team to the district
championship
first time in what the 100 plus years of
the school
it was austin there was no golf was the
only school
only sport in the school that didn't
have a banner and i said to my buddy
who's the ad i said within five years
you
have to get one up there we got it in
our fourth year would you rather win a
state
championship for your golf team or make
the cut
at the pga championship make the cut
every single time
[Laughter]
that you okay all right i thought you
were gonna be you're a teacher
and you know it's always about the kids
and nope it's all it's about you
it's all about me this week absolutely
will you walk over will you see tiger
did you see tiger
at all i walked by him on the range
yesterday i actually cut into the same
hole as his on tuesday
um we're in the same wave so i'll see
him at some point later today
as he's warming up yeah but does he say
anything to you
on the uh putting green
because he has his air pods in he's
listening
okay cool i went up to him and said the
rough's really heavy
he kind of looked up through this plan
she's like yeah it is and then went back
to his routine
um he did take his airpods out for
brooks kepca so i think if i was a
little bit
better in the world ranking he'd talk to
me and you're uh you're you're carrying
the callaway bag there and flying the
colors there we love that
absolutely they've been awesome to me it
they it's been great but on some of
their podcasts
phil saw that too that's why it came
back over it's just been it's been
absolutely dream week as i keep saying
every day is better than
before even though i shot a little worse
than i would have liked it still
it was incredible and i i acquitted
myself well i didn't shoot a hundred out
there i just shot seven over so it
wasn't terrible
and you're going to tee off at around
what uh
5 5 45 our time east coast time
yes 542 east coast 5 42. so we'll
hopefully they'll have you in the
coverage there do something
incredible will you alex just like i
mean can you do something so we can
you know make don't break a club or
anything like that
well no i i'll just push down in my
driveway
i like kept like uh deshambo did
yesterday breaking
the head of his driver that was crazy
hey it's a great story
and uh hopefully you you have some great
memories there
and um don't screw up today on the
driving range or the putting green okay
i'll try not to i want to keep those
guys safe but i was thinking
if i just took out ten of them my
teachers get a little bit
thank you alex we appreciate your time
good luck that's great
uh alex knoll k-n-o-l-l
and uh math teacher the high school golf
coach
and all of a sudden you go to a website
you click on you go
uh i'm playing in the pj championship